here it is it's the apple watch series
7.
it has a larger display a new case shape
with softer rounded edges a brighter
screen more durable front crystal more
resistant to dust and optimized user
interface for increased readability
faster charging and all new aluminum
colors alright so i unboxed this while i
was visiting my family and i didn't have
the light i barely had any equipment to
make the video so i tried the best that
i could but i wish that i was filming my
reaction when i would have actually
opened this thing up because the most
shocking thing is the color that i
received from my review unit is the new
green aluminum it has like this really
nice kind of hint of green and it's dark
enough that i feel like you'll be able
to mix this with various different color
bands and it won't be this huge
contrasting color mix up because it is
green it's sort of a soft and subtle
hint of green and i am actually very
surprised how much i like this color now
for my personal watch i did choose the
starlight color but this green is
actually quite surprising so i've been
using this watch for about a week now
and i haven't really been filming many
workouts or doing that much stuff
because i think that i may have injured
my knee about to go my first run with a
new apple watch i'm very excited it's a
little chilly
[Music]
oh no
um
i'm not even a mile in and sometimes
hills bother my knee and i almost gave
out running down this hill so i
now have to take it a little bit easier
because i was ready to push through i
was ready to really break some records
today
not today so the thing that really
surprised me about this watch was this
leather link band now this is about a
year old these came out last year but
for some reason i
never checked out this watch band and it
is honestly
really really cool it's a very light
kind of leather material and it's
magnetic so it just all
instantly clasps itself together just
like that and as you guys can see in
this lighting you can tell that this
aluminum case has that green hint
especially with this watch band because
it really does accent that green color
i'm just upset because it took me a year
to find out about this watch bands so if
this is a watch band that you haven't
tried yet i definitely recommend it so
one of the questions that so many people
have been asking and a lot of people
have been talking about all over the
internet is if i have a series six
should i upgrade to the series seven and
honestly if you have some extra cash and
this is something that you want to spend
your money on yeah go for it because the
bigger display and the new optimize
interface is pretty significant
especially if you're going from
something that is previous to a series 6
or if you've never had an apple watch
before this is it now before we get more
into this watch let's take a quick walk
down apple watch history lane to see
where we started at and where we are now
the first apple watch was released in
2015 and has been referred to as the
series zero this shipped without gps or
cellular but it did have a built-in
heart rate sensor the second generation
had two models the series one was
available only in aluminum starting at a
lower price with no gps or water
resistance unlike the series 2 which was
the first version to introduce gps
tracking with water resistance of 50
meters and the ability to track laps and
distance during swimming workouts it
also had a brighter display and it came
in aluminum stainless steel and ceramic
in 2017 we had the series 3 with a
faster processor bluetooth 4.2 a
built-in altimeter increased ram and was
the first version with lte for an always
connected watch series 4 has a much
larger display with thinner bezels and a
newly redesigned ceramic back this was
also the first watch that introduced ecg
and fall detect this is where i feel
like apple really started getting
serious about the health tracking
allowing anyone to take an
electrocardiogram right on their wrist
at any time in 2019 the series 5 brought
us the always-on low power display a
compass doubled the storage and brought
back the ceramic model and two new
titanium models in 2020 we got both the
series six and a lower cost se model the
series six has blood o2 tracking a new
faster processor a brighter display
always on altimeter and the ability to
connect to 5g wi-fi this also includes
the new third-gen optical heart rate
sensor the sc was a much lower cost
model that has the always-on altimeter
but it does have the older processor and
a second gen optical heart rate sensor
with no ecg blood o2 or the always-on
display continuing to improve the
battery life and fitness tracking with
each generation the series 6 has by far
been my favorite iteration since its
launch so i am so excited to see this
updated refresh version of this in the
seven this larger always on retina
display has about twenty percent more
screen area than the six and over fifty
percent more screen area than the series
three it has a new refined shape with
the softer edges and this front crystal
now bends light from the screen around
the edges for this subtle wrap around
effect now with this larger display
you'll be able to take advantage of the
optimized ui with larger text buttons
and everything overall is so much more
legible there's also a new text input
with a full keyboard and the ability to
use quick path where you swipe along the
keyboard to form words i do actually use
quick path a lot when i'm typing on my
iphone but most of the time from the
apple watch i just use my voice and
dictate and hit send now much like
previous apple watches we have some new
watch faces that are exclusive to the
seven now this is contour and this wraps
all around the new display and around
the edges the numbers also increase in
size on the hour and of course like all
the other watch faces you can change the
color but this one is set to green to
match the apple watch this is the
modular duo which gives you two large
complications and this world tag really
takes advantage of the larger display
showcasing so much information for all
of these time zones all at once the
entire charging system for series 7 has
also been redesigned to accommodate
faster charging with this new magnetic
fast usbc cable now you can still use
older chargers but you won't get the
full fast charge capabilities unless you
use this new one you'll be able to tell
the old and new chargers apart because
the new fast charger has this aluminum
outer ring it'll take just 45 minutes to
charge from zero to eighty percent and
in just eight minutes of charging
that'll be enough for eight hours of
sleep tracking i am really sad though
because i love the magsafe duo and i
won't be able to get the fast charging
if i'm using that for both my phone and
my watch but honestly i haven't had a
single problem with battery life on my
series six in the past year so i'm not
really that worried about it as for
colors this year in the series seven
there are five all-new aluminum colors
there's midnight starlight the green
that you've seen throughout this video
blue and product red so for my personal
one i chose starlight i also got an
abundance of cables cables no these are
watch bands i am so obsessed with this
leather link like i can't believe that
i've missed out on a whole year of this
incredible watch band and i also got the
solo loop chalk color so i basically
would have those two combinations of my
wallet and phone combo this is the new
clover watch band
i put it on my old watch i want to open
up this other color leather link and see
how this looks on the green because that
was my biggest concern is if i got the
green how would it look mix and match
with other colors
leather link you are a sleeper hit and
why did nobody tell me about how
cool this was oh that plum is gonna
actually look very good on this oh my
god a little duo a little two-tone
action oh yeah look at that
a nice little
mix and match let's check out this new
braided solo loop
look at you
man i love apple watch bands it's just
so
it's just like such a fun little
accessory oh jenna is asking me if do we
hate this no we
love it
oh look at that oh my god i did it
said so we can make that text size like
i have it at the smallest possible but
like look
look how big this could be
in all seriousness though i do like the
sweater
another huge benefit to having the apple
watch is you'll have access to apple
fitness plus and this is something that
i've talked about a lot and i love apple
fitness plus i love the instructors i
love the classes i love the way that the
apple watch integrates into the classes
you're able to see all of your metrics
that just pops up right there in apple
fitness you can use apple tv you can do
it on your iphone you can join your ipad
and i've been using it a lot to do
workouts on my ipad and over the past
week when i got this apple watch i was
in maryland with my family on a little
mini getaway vacation in a little cabin
in the middle of the woods i would have
filmed more there but i uh i think i
hurt my knee and i basically was just
kind of resting the whole trip i did a
few runs testing out the watch and i was
like i think that i may be injured so i
went back inside watched squid game and
um ate ice cream
but going back to apple fitness i have
so many different classes even though i
wasn't feeling up to doing some intense
running they have so many classes that i
was like okay i'm gonna find some low
impact classes i can do some yoga i can
do some stretching and there's so many
things that like the apple watch has
like these hidden little gems they even
have this time to walk and this is
something that i never really talked
about in a video but it's really cool
they have this wide array of basically
like podcast style talks that they have
with various different people and you
can browse their entire library you can
listen to a couple of these oh like nick
jonas jane fonda john chu need to
download them and go for a walk it's
cool because you can download them from
the cloud so you'll be able to just
listen to them directly off of your
watch again fitness plus huge fan love
the way that it integrates with the
apple watch and it's just such a great
thing because while i was traveling i
obviously didn't have a peloton
treadmill with me i also didn't have any
weights or anything all i had was my
apple watch and my ipad and i was able
to still get a good workout even with my
minor injury which now a week later it's
feeling much better i did want to show
you guys the watch face that i do
normally use blood oxygen which i do
like to check frequently and this middle
bar is the heart rate data throughout i
guess the day which is kind of cool
because i can see like i did not work
out today so my heart rate did not even
go above 89 which is pretty subpar but i
can see like my highest and lowest heart
rate so my lowest heart rate was 47 and
i have access to my messages i can see
my activity rings and be able to start a
workout but with the apple watch
everything is stored inside of the
fitness app and this is where you can
also find fitness plus which like i said
gives you access to all sorts of
workouts another new thing that apple
fitness plus just recently launched is
meditation so now they have some new
guided meditations it's cool because
they do give you an option to watch the
trainers as they're leading you in the
meditation or you can do it with audio
only in their new mindfulness app so you
can do the audio meditations and this
will even give you an option to reflect
to breathe i'm sure if you used an apple
watch long enough you've definitely got
the notifications to take some time to
breathe even a minute of deep breathing
can calm you and usually it happens at
the time where i am the least calm and
the last thing that i want to do is
breathe or be calm so then i get even
more fired up because i'm like i know
that what you're telling me is right and
i should do it and what do i do
eighty-five percent of the time i just
click out of it and then those
few times that i do take the minute to
breathe i'm like wow i feel so much
better i feel like that's kind of
applicable to like why didn't i listen
to my parents when they told me
something a long time ago until you
figure it out for yourself or learn the
hard way you just don't learn do you i
just love that they also have a lot of
programs and stuff for beginners so you
have the meditations for beginners and
they also have this new thing that is
getting you ready for various activities
so the new one is get ready for snow
season so these are activities geared
specifically towards skiing we've got
workouts for beginners workouts for
older adults workouts for pregnancy so
they definitely have a wide array of
things and again
fitness plus is really only a year old
so it's kind of cool to see how far it's
evolved to where it is now and it really
makes me excited to see what they do in
the future some other things that i like
about the apple watch is the
competitions this isn't a new feature
but it is really fun to send these
friendly competition requests to your
friends let's see let's send
jenna a competition okay the fact that
she has 22 wins and i only have three
that's
that's pathetic huh
all right to be fair sometimes i can't
track a lot of my workouts because i
don't like to wear my apple watch when i
do jiu-jitsu or knife training i am so
that's my excuse and i'm sticking to it
so while sleep tracking to me is very
important i just recently got an aura
ring which a lot of you guys have been
asking about this ring that i've been
wearing you're like what happened is
there something you're not telling us um
actually yeah there is something i'm not
telling you i wasn't telling you that
i've been tracking my sleep for the past
couple of months there i'm really glad
that i can get that out of the open and
now you guys all know my secret so i
haven't really talked to you guys about
this but i am working on a full video to
kind of give you some more information
about it this gives you a lot of very
similar information but it also does
track your temperature so it will be
tracking your temperature throughout the
night it tracks your movement it tracks
your breathing rate your heart rate and
it really gives you this comprehensive
list of how your sleep actually went it
gives you tips on things that you could
have done better it also gives you
access to your readiness so this uses
things like your resting heart rate body
temperature hrv balance and your
recovery how much you slept last night
all of these little factors to determine
how well you're rested and ready for
training now i've really been into
tracking my sleep on the ring is because
it is so small and light like it doesn't
even feel like i'm wearing anything but
the way that i sleep is usually i sleep
on my stomach and this is the hand that
usually is like sort of close to my face
so i end up sleeping on my apple watch
instead of like my hand and it's not
very comfortable but for me i much
rather prefer wearing this tiny small
little ring to sleep but that's not to
say that these two things don't go
so incredibly well together because i
use the apple watch to track all of my
fitness that only enhances the aura ring
significantly because you're getting all
of this accurate heart rate data this
fitness tracking that the ring doesn't
do so i do feel like this is such a
perfect combo especially if you're
training for various things this really
does kind of give you the hard true
facts and data of how well you slept how
much you recovered and what you may need
to do to improve for your next night's
sleep this was just a first look at the
apple watch series 7. i have absolutely
been loving it as somebody who is a huge
apple watch fan it's been great the
display has made such a huge difference
i've also noticed the display is
brighter but after using it the past
week it kind of just seems normal now so
i don't even remember what it was like
before it still does look very similar i
feel like if a lot of people were to put
these up side by side i think a normal
everyday person may not be able to tell
but for those who may be applewatch
obsessed there is a good chance that you
will be able to notice some of the
subtle differences and be like yep there
it is that's the series 7. i hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it a thumbs up and make
sure you subscribe so you'll be notified
when i post new videos hit the bell
leave me some comments and i will see
you guys in the next video
[Music]
you